welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and zack snyder's justice league
triumphantly restores the director's
original vision not just for this film
but for the full dc cinematic universe
he helped launch
in this video let's break down the
changes zack snyder made from the
theatrical version to this 4-hour
director's cut
though it's not really fair to call them
changes because they're really fixes
clearing away the unnecessary
compromises of the 2017 film to reveal
the pure narrative zack snyder always
intended so right away
snyder opens with superman's death in
batman v superman via doomsday
with his death cry blasting out to the
horizon a literal death rattle ringing
that bell of the mother boxes in
atlantis and themyscira and in the home
of silas stone this replaces the reshot
prologue of the cellphone footage of
henry cavill with that poorly cgi'd
upper lip since cavill contractually
needed to keep his mustache for the
mission impossible fallout film when
this whole reshot was going down so now
we get this great visual depiction of
what lex luthor was warning about that
this kryptonian protector's death awoke
these sleeping mother boxes
alerting steppenwolf that earth was left
unprotected and hearing khalil's cry
gus past us links his life force with
this particular alien tech setting it up
to bring him back later lois visits the
heroes park memorial zack snyder himself
actually cameos in the coffee shop
it's actually a fun meta way he said he
was storyboarding this exact shot jimmy
olsen actor mark mcclure from the
richard donner superman films cameos as
a park cop
instead of the central city desk cop he
was in the theatrical cut and you've
noticed how snyder put all of this in
the ratio of 1.33 to 1 or 4 to 3
according to cinematographer fabian
wagner and he did this to be able to
frame character movement more vertically
since many of them fly and leap and
swing battle axes from up to down
as characters tend to do in comic book
panels as opposed to the traditional
cinema left to right movement also this
cut was rescored by junkie xl
past collaborated with hans zimmer on
many of these dc films his percussion
and his haunting melodies tie
all of this together really really well
gone is the actual
batman rooftop opening in which he sees
three mother boxes in green parademon
blood instead we get a prolonged tyke
through the icelandic glaciers as bruce
looks for arthur
and arthur's departure is serenaded by
townsfolk singing an icelandic folk song
[Music]
wonder woman's london rescue is extended
to the moment where she greets and
inspires this young girl
can i be like you someday you can be
anything you want to be
but perhaps the biggest character change
of this cut steppenwolf
now arrives in the themiscure revolt
showing off some
sick looking armor later he uses this
armor to close and snap all the arrows
with the flex
removed was the old potatoey design who
kept calling motherbox's mother
and the opening exchange is now i have
come to enlighten you
to the great darkness i will bathe
in your fear daughters of them
show him your fear we
and then after an even more brutal loss
to steppenwolf the amazonians arrow of
artemis and the shrine of the amazons
leads to an
extended sequence of diana descending
into the ruins to find this chamber
detailing the history of the ancient war
against darkseid aquaman's fisherman
rescue no longer features that moment
where he has parademon green blood on
his hand afterwards the song there is a
kingdom now plays over his sexy wave
greeting and not so sexy littering
though we do now see him bicker with
willem davao as his mentor volco about
hating atlantis and not wanting to take
his mother's trident all taking place at
the foot of the statue of the ancient
king atlan we finally learn more of
steppenwolf's backstory via these chats
with darkseid's lieutenant desaad
steppenwolf was a disgraced general
hoping to be allowed to return home to
apocalypse by conquering 10 000 worlds
for dark side and he explains that his
pair demons can sense the scent of the
other two mother boxes and he ends by
saying
which actually later end up being among
his last words before superman blocks
his death blow dark side
diana explains to bruce this ancient war
it's this glorious expanded sequence now
including dark side in this battle zeus
is flanked by
ares with david thulis's face from
wonder woman showing up here
artemis beside them with her shooting
arm glowing there's a past green lantern
there to help and he goes down fast
dark side cuts off his hand and the ring
almost goes to dark side before
artemis's arrow hits him back and it
zips away
ships roll up with the atlanteans
including king atlan hippolytus there
and robin wright cameos again it's all
very 300 and lord of the ringsy i love
it and it feels like such a triumph to
see these defenders of earth repel these
[__] bookending the justice
league's badass victory at the end
if they could do it back then we could
do it again snyder restores barry
allen's beautiful rescue of iris west
and a cascade of hot dogs it's just so
sweet and heartbreaking as barry's only
able to have these little connections
and a fleeting moment to the rest of us
guys gotta be so lonely another added
scene shows steppenwolf and parademons
dragging atlanteans from the ocean
using a mechanized starrow to scan their
thoughts
starro is a parasitic hivemind from dc
comics
and it sounds like he's confirmed to
show up in james gunn suicide squad
later this summer but victor stone's
cyborg gets one of the biggest
restorations in this film he's now truly
the beating heart of it we see his
backstory as a gcu football star his
father silas missing the game
his mother dr stone defending him to a
gcu dean for hacking the grades of a
friend going through a tough time and
then their fatal car collision
vic reawakens in his mind's eye
exploring his new powers as cyborg i
love the sequence
showing his potential to control all
world weaponry and financial systems
depicted with the wall street bull
fighting a russian bear
which she just clears aside to
redistribute the wealth of this
downtrodden server
and single mom if you had 1400 in your
account this week you can thank cyborg
bruce's recruitment of barry allen goes
roughly the same except snyder left out
barry's
brunch rant bruce still throws a
batarang directly at the face of someone
he's not totally certain it's fast
enough to dodge it i love it but then
god this one got me snyder extends this
showing bruce and barry driving past
this billboard and it reads you are not
alone
it's a wonderful reminder to all those
struggling out there
from the american foundation for suicide
prevention afsp.org
really reminding us of the guiding force
for zack snyder we get a few more alfred
scenes including him trying to help
diana make some tea
and building bruce's new gauntlets that
can absorb kryptonian blasts of energy
and there's also a new later moment when
alfred lectures bruce about all the
king's horses how you can't really face
the charging bull don't wave the red
cape
we also get more seeds with vick's
father silas stone and his assistant
ryan choi whom the epilogue sets up as
the future
atom steppenwolf's attack on atlantis is
more fleshed out including this new
moment with mira
you can't escape i'm not trying to
whoa so mira is a water bender and she
has just used her power to suck out the
water from steppenwolf inside this air
pocket including his
blood she is a bloodbender victor
explains a new historical sequence
showing how the third mother box was
found in world war ii germany
and then got into silas hands later on
which he then used to give vic his
cyborg body and from this the team
deduces that they can use the same tech
to reanimate superman
meanwhile there's a new scene where
steppenwolf realizes the anti-life
equation is on earth and alerts darkseid
that he's close to conquering the planet
it's great we understand who the
villains are
how they're working together what their
opposing team strategy is but then there
is this
crazy new lois and martha scene that
ends with martha
shape-shifting into the martian
manhunter and then back into his human
disguise of
general swanwick harry linux the world
needs you too lois
so the reason that he posed as martha
here is he needed lois to stay in the
game and suggesting that he knows that
lois is the key to superman but before
we continue online shopping has
basically become the only shopping
that's where today's sponsor honey comes
in
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for coupon codes and
then automatically tests them when
you're checking out here's how it works
you get honey on your computer for free
and two easy clicks and then when you're
checking out on one of its 30 000
supported sites honey pops up and all
you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons for that site
if honey finds a working code
you'll watch the prices drop honey
showed me a special deal when i went to
buy some athletic shorts that helped me
save almost three bucks on top of the
deal the website was running
those of you who have already installed
honey using my link have found over 483
dollars in savings so it's simple if you
have a computer honey should be on it
it's free and it works with whatever
browser you use
get honey for free today by going to
joinhoney.com
new rockstars that's join honey.com new
rockstar so they know i sent you
thanks to honey for sponsoring this
video the resurrection sequence now
includes flash and cyborg exhuming clark
without that pet cemetery joke and then
later in the ship snyder includes this
new line from the flash setting up his
time reversal powers
i don't like to break this rule but when
i approach the speed of light i
look crazy things happen to time but if
i do it i create massive electrical
power
and that is exactly what we see in this
re-edited sequence the tiniest reversal
to sink barry's speed force with the
moment the motherbox hits the fluid
setting up his big move in the final act
meanwhile we cut to lois in another new
scene revealing a pregnancy test in her
drawer actually in
epilogue their return to kent farm
snyder edited
over her u-haul box with a baby basket
and looped in bruce congratulating clark
congratulations by the way but one of
the scariest inclusions that snyder had
here right before they bring back
superman
victor is given a haunting premonition
the unity completes the planet gets
destroyed dark side is sitting atop his
throne diana is on a funeral pyre
dark side stabs arthur with his own
trident and kills other atlanteans with
omega beams black suit superman
in the batcave you can see the robin
suit back there cradling the charred
corpse of lois
and then savage superman hovering over
the ruins of wayne manor holding
batman's mask that he pulled off in that
bbs nightmare scene dead green lantern
kilowog on the ruins
thomas wayne portrait diana shield
aquaman's trident and
the joker truce card torn in half the
hero's park battle
now ends not with superman saying do you
bleed and ragdolling batman into that
dumb joke where he couldn't get up
now batman uses these new gauntlets to
absorb and block superman's heat vision
such a cooler way for it to end
steppenwolf taking the third motherbox
now adds the death of silas stone
sacrificing himself
to super heat the box so that they can
track it to the stronghold
we see superman reentering the
kryptonian ship in another re-added
scene finding various alternate
kryptonian suits as the voices of both
father figures jor
l russell crowe and jonathan kent kevin
costner speak to him
and we get this flight sequence
paralleling his first flight in man of
steel emerging from this same ship
portal now zack snyder said he wanted to
include superman's black suit as a nod
to the suit he first wears after his
resurrection in the comics he also
wanted to give him a mullet too but he
ended i'm not doing that so the black
color scheme isn't just to look cool
this suit is specifically designed for
healing it's more efficient at absorbing
solar energy which is why he ends this
flight soaking in the sunlight another
new scene features bruce telling diana
about his batcave vision of barry and
batman v superman
taking place in that same spot he
believes it signals something darker
meaning the future that victor saw
and in the epilogue snyder also revised
their take off in the flying fox
you fixed it it wanted to fly flight is
its nature
yours too he'll be here alfred i know it
what makes you so sure faith alfred
notice their faces look a little
composited here snyder added this to
give bruce a moment to empower victor
and to restore alfred's faith ahead of
his meeting with superman which
schneider also put back in
no that's hope you're not too late
for most of the final battle the most
obvious visual change is just the
removal of the red sky restoring it to
the deeper tones that it was in the
early trailers snyder also took out the
whole russian family subplot the
dostoyevsky joke the advice of just save
one person oh and
while we were at it some other thing
snyder took out the gag with arthur
sitting on diana's lasso
barry's moment where he kind of
motorboarded diana in the tunnel
sequence which reportedly had to be done
with a stunt double
the scene with diana stretching out
bruce that random dumb dirty rag
covering batman's reveal atop gcpd with
gordon cyborg saying booyah
and that whole fastest man alive raced
in the end credits bye-bye
but there are some huge changes that
come as the battle ends
first superman's arrival he no longer
appears behind stephanov saying i know
truth but i'm also a big fan of justice
instead he pops in right in front of
steppenwolf's final axe blow and uses
his freeze breath to shatter it
then he beats the crap out of
steppenwolf emitting these shock waves
with every punch
echoing his death cries in the opening
scene and he heat visions off one of
steppenwolf's horns whatever that thing
is but
even more dramatic for the implications
on the dceu
barry's plan to run laps to build up
speed force in order to knock cyborg in
the mother boxes gets derailed when he
gets shot in the side
and so they miss their window the unity
occurs they
lose good day sirs but then barry breaks
his rule
okay just gotta go faster than the speed
of light far beyond the speed of light
you gotta break the rule barry and
you've gotta do it now
notice how with every step that
crumbling terrain reforms
he is out running the reversal of the
world's destruction
back to the moment of unity even
graphically through the re-materializing
flesh of superman and cyborg
flashpoint time travel looks amazing
also new is victor's battle
inside the mother boxes realizing he is
not alone in that the projections of his
family are just tricks by the mother
boxes
trying to get in his head and they
revert into these creepy white-haired
demon ladies
mother boxer superman ends up helping
him pull him apart
leading to snyder's amazing three punch
fatality on steppenwolf
with only one of his antler things
remaining his severed head
leans at darkseid's foot who just stomps
it all flat
yuck darkseid glares at them through the
boom tube portal and tells assad and
granny goodness to ready the armada
leading to this largely new epilogue
shots of victor listening to silas's
recorded message of fatherly wisdom
arthur departing volkow and mira batman
on his war machine tank from the dark
knight returns
superman ripping open his shirt to the
black and silver emblem and then an
extended version of lex's escape from
prison and meeting with deathstroke and
then this creepy post-apocalyptic
sequence with bruce and victor's
premonitions come true
batman leads cyborg flash wearing armor
mirror and deathstroke so presumably
arthur and wonder woman are dead and
they add in jared leto joker who taunts
him over robin
he knows exactly what it's like to lose
so many loves
like an adopted son batman counters with
some interesting words about harley
quinn because when i hit harley quinn
she begged me and when i killed you
and make no mistake i will kill you
then i do it slow snyder said this was
the one new scene that he wrote without
it being part of his original justice
league film for what this all means and
the implications check out my indian
explained video and of course the final
scene features bruce meeting martian
manhunter at his lakeside home fade to
black for
autumn leonard cohen's hallelujah cover
over credits a completely new film folks
really these changes are best
appreciated by watching the full snyder
cut
in its totality however many sittings it
takes you trust me it's worth it at the
end of the day
if you haven't done it and just watch
this video to get a sense of what the
changes are you still won't be
disappointed by just
watching this beautiful looking four
hours of storytelling follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for everything you love thank you for
watching
booyah i'm just kidding we're not we're
not doing that
[Music]
you